primero que todo quiero evocar ante
nuestros compatriotas que nos miran
expresar mi solidaridad y compasión
absoluta con el pueblo ucraniano
considero que la agresión de que fue
víctima ucrania no es admisible
confieso que los esfuerzos señor marco
que ustedes han hecho para encontrar el
nombre de francia los medios y las vías
para llegar a la paz merecen apoyo eso
es muy claro la ayuda a ucrania y por
supuesto ayuda humanitaria eugenia por
supuesto ayuda financiera eugenia claro
que sí ayuda en material de defensa
claro que sí por supuesto como ustedes
saben el alcalde de opinión fue hasta la
frontera de polonia para traer algunos
refugiados mujeres niños ancianos
ucranianos y ponerlos en el lugar seguro
en pepiño
polonia ha recibido cerca de 3 millones
de refugiados ya
las alertas que yo en algún momento
lancé era para expresar mi límite entre
la ayuda y la cobelli gerencia en
materia de entrega de armas
y en nuestro límite se refería a las
sanciones yo estaba de acuerdo
estuve de acuerdo con todas las
sanciones que fueron tomadas contra los
oligarcas contra los bancos etcétera la
única sanción
contra la cual con la cual yo no estuve
de acuerdo es el bloqueo de la
importación del gas y el petróleo rusos
porque porque pienso que ese no es el
mejor método pienso que eso no le hará
ningún daño a rusia y sobre todo si le
va a hacer mucho mal al pueblo francés y
pienso que las consecuencias de ese
bloqueo nos han anunciado que sería
negociado por la unión europea después
de la elección presidencial francesa
pienso entonces que este bloqueo tendría
consecuencias cataclísmicas no solamente
sobre los particulares sino también para
las empresas pienso entonces que no se
puede uno hacer el harakiri
eran en realidad causarle mal financiero
a rusia que seguramente irá a vender su
gas y su petróleo a otros países este
fue el único límite que yo expresé
también exprese un temor de expresión
temor que es un temor antiguo de nuestro
país y de otras grandes potencias del
mundo se trata del temor
de que rusia y chinas se conviertan en
aliados muy estrechos esto constituiría
mañana porque gobernar es prevé prever
los peligros de hoy responder a ellos y
los peligros de mañana que no se
conviertan en unasur en un superpoder
económico monetario incluso que se
conviertan en un súper pueden militar lo
que podría constituir un peligro muy
grave para occidente para europa y para
francia
[Música]
esos son los límites que yo exprese las
alertas que lance porque creo y lo
repito que estamos obligados en un mundo
complejo como el que tenemos hoy a
proyectarse a mediano plazo y a largo
plazo